[Music]
[Music]
we all remember that Bob from the year
2000
fast forward 18 years singer Craig David
is still churning out music that just
makes you feel good his new album the
time is now dropped in January
[Music]
how does everything feel this is your
seventh studio album it's amazing you
know it feels like the first time yes
that's the and I didn't know like maybe
there would be an album that would like
feel just like when I first died off but
the time is now feels like that because
I was 1718 when I made the first night
yeah
I didn't it wasn't thinking anything
about where it was gonna go what was
gonna do I was as loud as want to make
great songs 7 million albums later there
was something in so I think just go back
to that that frame of mind the 36 year
old singer has found success as a singer
and DJ he's got a summer residency in
Ibiza but his love life that's still a
work in progress you have said that you
know you're at a point in your life
where you are eager to find your soul
mate and you would love to have children
someday what's the status on that have
you found somebody not about the decades
you know when you meet your twin flame
my thing is they're never really
foreseeable to kind of keep looking
because it all hit you one time where
you're just like I know what is it that
catches your attention what is it you're
looking for in a mate I just see
something just to is comfortable in
themselves you know I just want them to
be you to be the most authentic you not
to conform not to try and be anything
different than what you are because
that's what makes you beautiful I just
want to encourage anyone and as if it's
my family or as like my future wife
children just to be you Craig also
opened up about his most high-profile
rumored romance to date you were rumored
to have dated Sofia Vergara in 2003 is
this true
I think there's pictures that would say
that we definitely knew each other very
very well I mean people would say it's
dating someone people say his friends
what do you remember most about hanging
out with her I just remember a very
beautiful soul who just had was just
caring about our family she's just the
lovely gal she Rico still in touch
nice picture so here for many many years
I always see her from afar and I've got
a lot of love in my heart but seeing her
kind of turn into this incredible
actress that she is it's been amazing to
watch from afar it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]